UNLIKE ANYTHING WE HAVE EVER
SEEN.
ONLY GOING TO GET WORSE.
THE MORE SUCCESSFUL THE
PRESIDENT IS, THE HARDER THE
MEDIA IS GOING TO TRY TO
DESTROY HIM.
JOINING US WITH REACTION
FORMER WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY SEAN SPICER AND
FORMER DEPUTY ASSISTANT TO
THE PRESIDENT FOX NEWS
NATIONAL SECURITY STRATEGIST
DR. GORKA.
SEAN SPICER, JUST LOOK AT
THESE NUMBERS.
3 MILLION JOBS HAVE BEEN
CREATED.
MEASURE NOW IS ON A PATH
TOWARDS ENERGY INDEPENDENCE.
HE HAS GOTTEN RID OF MORE
REGULATIONS THAN ANY OTHER
ADMINISTRATION IN RECORD
TIME.
HIS TAX CUT DEAL IS DONE.
THE EMPLOYER MANDATE IS
DONE.
AND, LO AND BEHOLD, ROCKET
MAN IS GOING TO SIT DOWN
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
WHO WOULD HAVE THUNK IT?
>> IDENTIFIES SIS IS ON THE
RUN.
BORDER CROSSINGS ARE DOWN.
JUDICIARY IS BEING MADE WITH
CONSERVATIVE JUDGES.
HE IS STANDING UP FOR HIGH
OF WE CAN GO ON AND ON AND
ON.
THE PRESIDENT IS PROMISING
TO RACK UP RESULTS.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
INTERESTING YOU TOUCHED ON
IT THE BOTTOM LINE AS HE
GETS RESULTS, THEY TRY TO
TALK ABOUT CHAOS AND
PROFITS.
MOST AMERICANS CARE WHETHER
OR NOT THEIR COUNTRIES AND
LIVE ARES ARE IMPROVING.
MAKING THIS COUNTRY A BETTER
PLACE AND MAKING IT SAFER.
MAKING THE ECONOMY BETTER.
BETTER WAGES U WHAT PEOPLE
VOTE FOR AT THE END OF THE
DAY, TO MAKE THEIR LIVES,
THE HIVES OF THEIR NEIGHBORS
AND FELLOW CITIZENS BETTER.
THE PRESIDENT IS ACHIEVING
THOSE RESULTS.
WHAT HAPPENS IS THE
PRESIDENT TURNS AND TRIES TO
FIGURE OUT HOW CAN WE FOCUS
ON THE PROCESS STORY.
HOW CHAOS AND STUFF LIKE
THAT.
AOPPOSED TO THE RESULT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS DOING
EXACTLY WHAT HE SAID HE
WOULD DO ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL.
WASHINGTON IS LITTERED WITH
CAMPAIGN -- WITH POLITICIANS
THAT MAKE PROMISES OVER AND
OVER AGAIN AND THEN DON'T
FULFILL THEM.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS DOING
EXACTLY WHAT HE SAID HE WAS
GOING TO DO AND HE IS
GETTING THE RESULTS THAT HE
SAID HE WOULD GET.
>> Sean: YEAH.
AFTER 8 YEARS OF OBAMA.
13 MILLION MORE AMERICANS ON
FOOD STAMPS.
8 MORE ON POVERTY.
LOWEST LABOR PARTICIPATION
RATE SINCE THE 1970S, HE
DOUBLED THE DEBT.
LOWEST HOME OWNERSHIP IN 51
YEARS.
ALL REBOUND NEW A YEAR AND
TAX CUTS ARE NOW ONLY JUST
KICKING IN.
DR. GORKA?
>> THAT'S THE MOST
REMARKABLE THING.
HADN'T ISN'T 1 MONTHS INTO
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
THE KIND OF THINGS THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS ACHIEVED,
YOU WOULD BE PROUD OF THEM
IF YOU WERE AN 8 YEAR DOUBLE
TERM PRESIDENT.
RIGHT.
LOOK, THE OBSESSION WITH
PROCESS, IF THIS IS CHAOS,
SEAN, GIVE ME MORE CHAOS.
GIVE ALL MINERS MORE
GIVE ALL AINERS MORE
GIVE ALL AMEERS MORE
GIVE ALL AMERIS MORE
GIVE ALL AMERICAMORE
GIVE ALL AMERICANSRE
GIVE ALL AMERICANS MORE
CHAOS BECAUSE IT'S BRINGING
RESULTS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY,
SEAN --
>> Sean: IS THIS CHAOS?
AMERICA ELECTED AN
ADISRUPTER.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I DON'T THINK MOST AMERICANS
ARE GOING TO VOTE.
THEY DON'T LIKE DONALD
TRUMP'S TWEETS IF THEY HAVE
A MILLION DOLLARS MORE MONEY
IN THEIR POCKET.
>> WE LIVED IT.
THE BUILDING.
THE MORE THEY ATTACKED US
AND THE PRESIDENT, THE MORE
RENEW WE WERE DOING WHAT THE
PEOPLE ELECT I HAD THE
PRESIDENT TO DO.
>> ONE THING THAT'S
INTERESTING THOUGH IS THAT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE ON
TO THIS.
RIGHT?
IF YOU LOOK AT THE RATINGS
THAT CAME OUT.
LOOK AT THE PROGRAMS WHERE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE TUNING
IN TO.
THEY ARE TUNING OUT THE
MAINSTREAM NEWS AND TUNING
IN TO SHOWS LIKE YOURS AND
TUCKER AND LAURA'S AND OTHER
SHOWS ON FOX BECAUSE THEY
ARE TIRED OF NOT BEING TOLD
WHAT'S GREG ON.
MARKET RESEARCH PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING
AND CHANGING VIEWER HABITS